good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm trey gowdy
thank you again for joining us tonight
impeachment starts next week
nancy pelosi said house democrats were
moving forward with impeachment to quote
protect the constitution and then she
slipped up
and told you the truth listen to this
the house managers are walking into a
trial where all signs
point to acquittal they don't know that
they haven't heard the case
and the court of the senate they will
make their case in the court of public
opinion
they will make their case i have great
confidence in them and we'll see
we'll see if it's going to be a senate
of courage
or cowardice
do you hear that the court of public
opinion she says
well it would have to be the court of
public opinion because what you will see
next week bears no similarity to a real
court
in real court there's a judge who is
fair and neutral
next week the presiding judge is senator
patrick leahy
who has already voted twice to convict
and remove donald trump from office
he would never be allowed to preside in
a real court
in real court there is a jury of women
and men who have not already made up
their minds
that is really the only one quality you
must have to serve on a real jury in a
real court
there are 50 democrats who will vote to
convict next week no matter what the
evidence is
in real court the jury is told to wait
until the very end to reach any
conclusions in fact
you're forbidden from even beginning to
reach conclusions
until the very end but not next week
in real court they're rules of evidence
rules about what kind of evidence can be
admitted and how
and i doubt you'll see any of those
rules next week in real court there is
cross-examination
because as you know cross-examination is
the single best way to determine whether
a witness is telling the truth or not
there will be no cross-examination next
week because i don't think they're going
to be any witnesses next week
nancy pelosi says we will see if the
senate is made of courage
or cowardice i'll tell you what takes
real courage
it takes real courage to be fair to your
enemies
that takes courage anyone can protect
their friends and attack their enemies
real courage is when you're fair to
everyone even
those you don't like house prosecutors
have asked donald trump to testify
and he has refused their invitation
despite threats of a subpoena
those same prosecutors may ask the
senate to draw a
negative inference if he refuses to show
up
you know what happens in real court it's
exactly
the opposite prosecutors cannot comment
on the silence of a defendant
in real court and if you do not only
will you lose your case
you might lose your law license and
there is no negative inference in a real
prosecution
in fact it's the opposite you're
actually presumed
innocent so democrats are free to talk
about their court of public opinion
i would rather talk about real court
where real people make tough decisions
based on the facts
and the law regardless of politics
you know the rules and procedures we use
in real courtrooms are not
right and fair simply because we use
them in courtrooms
it's really the opposite we use those
rules and procedures in real courtrooms
because they are right and fair
it was the rightness and the fairness
that came first
but you won't see that next week
speaker pelosi if you're looking for a
court of public opinion
we actually have them they're called
elections
popularity wins in the other court
in the real court fairness wins
and what really takes courage is to know
the difference
between the two senator tom cotton has a
front row
seat to the democrats impeachment
theater he'll serve as one of the 100
jurors in next week's trial
and he joins us right now from the great
state of arkansas
senator tom cotton how are you tom i'm
good trey it's good to be on with you
good to see you guest hosting this week
thank you you know what i had going
through my mind when i heard cowardice
if i'm not mistaken you signed up for
combat
after law school not jag but con combat
so
coward would not be a word i used in
connection with you what do you think
about what she said
trey maybe maybe i joined the army as an
infantry officer it's a
just a reflection of what a bad lawyer i
was unlike you you know i heard speaker
pelosi say today that next week we'd see
if we have a senate of cowardice or
courage
but we know we have a house of fools
because they elected nancy pelosi
to be their speaker i mean look what
they did in this impeachment tray
they didn't have a single hearing not a
single witness not a single document
they rushed it over to the senate but
then they didn't actually deliver the
papers
uh in time to have a trial now they want
to proceed with a plainly
unconstitutional impeachment proceeding
to convict and remove a man from office
who left office
two weeks ago i think the american
people think it's pretty strange that
democrats are still
obsessing about donald trump when we're
actually trying to address
the problems that they face whether it's
people who are out of work or can't get
hours or can't get vaccinated or have
their schools closed
that's what the democrats should be
focused on that's what i'm focused on
now their threat you're married to a
real prosecutor i
i did it i was average but i did it for
a long time
uh we couldn't make defendants testify
and you can't draw a negative inference
if they don't in fact it's the opposite
what are the house managers talking
about making him come testify i mean if
they think he's committed a crime
doesn't he have the right
not to incriminate himself you would
think so
trey and also it contradicts exactly
what they've been saying for the last
three weeks they've been saying
they didn't need to have hearings they
didn't need to have witnesses they
didn't need to have documents that the
evidence
was manifest it was in front of
everyone's eyes on tv
that we all saw it if that's the case
why are they asking donald trump himself
to come testify
in person
what do you expect next week senator do
you think they're going to call
witnesses will there be examination
cross-examination exhibits like a real
like a real trial
i don't know trey uh i have not heard uh
the legal strategy from either the
president's legal team or from the house
managers as a juror
i'll sit and i'll listen to what
everything is said but my opinion has
been very clear from the day of the
house
past this russian impeachment that it's
beyond the constitutional authority of
the senate to have impeachment
proceedings to convict and remove from
office
now i served with you for a number of
years you do your homework so for you to
reach the conclusion that trying a
president who has left office violates
the constitution there must be a reason
for it what led you to that conclusion
well true you can just look at the
constitution itself it says explicitly
the president
the vice president and all civil
officers of the united states will be
susceptible to impeachment donald trump
is none of those things at this moment
then usually
when the text of any law to include the
constitution is plain
that's the end of it you don't have to
do much more research now i would also
point out that the democrats
have not invited chief justice john
roberts to sit at this impeachment trial
as the constitution requires the chief
justice to sit
at any trial of the president that just
further reinforces
that the democrats know that they are
not
holding a trial of the president they're
holding a trial really an inquest into a
private citizen
it's not constitutional nor should it be
the focus of the senate right now when
we're still
dealing with this pandemic and mass
unemployment
now you mentioned the pandemic what are
some of the other things the senate
could be doing
as i mean if 45 members of the jury say
you don't have jurisdiction you're not
ever going to get a conviction
so you're going through with a trial
where you cannot get a conviction
what could you be doing and should be
doing instead of this
well trey i wish we were working in a
bipartisan fashion to try to address the
needs of the american people for example
improved vaccine distribution in certain
states but look at what joe biden and
democrats are doing now
joe biden after preaching unity is
governing from the hard left
in a highly partisan fashion trey as you
know we passed five bills last year
spending more than four trillion dollars
to help combat this pandemic and a lot
of that money is still not spent
the average vote on those bills is over
90 u.s senators out of 100. in many
cases
we had a unanimous vote yet the very
first thing joe biden does is go to the
hard left and refuse to cooperate with
any republican
and now we're voting tonight on their
budget and look at what some of these
democrat or some of these amendments
that democrats are voting down
50 democrats just voted against
withholding covet relief money from
schools that don't reopen
even after their teachers are vaccinated
another 50
voted against denying money to cities
and counties that don't cooperate with
immigration enforcement
42 out of 50 democrats voted to give
stimulus checks to illegal aliens
it goes to show just how partisan and
how radical
the democrats in joe biden's washington
are governing right now
senator we got about one minute but it's
it
seems like some republicans are of the
opinion that if you're going to go
forward with this impeachment trial
we're going to have a difficult time
confirming your cabinet and he's chosen
impeachment
over cabinet we've got about 45 seconds
what's your reaction to that
well that's right trey i mean once the
senate is sitting as a court of
impeachment it takes precedence of
all other business so my suspicion is
that next week we won't have any votes
to confirm any of joe biden's cabinet he
has a few
of his cabinet members already confirmed
but this is just going to push us
further into february getting joe
biden's cabinet confirmed he coached the
show again
what their priority is their priority is
to continue to obsess
about donald trump even after his last
left office more than two weeks ago and
we have a lot of problems that we should
be addressing
tom thank you for joining us and i hope
you enjoy your jury service next week
thank you trey